MAKE HISR
PHILADELPHIA FIRE.
>> Brian: GOING TO SEEEE ON GOT
IN THE WAY OF THAT ANDLFVERBERGS
GOAL CREASE. THE POINT OF A
CROSS-ICE PASS TO ZEGRAS.
RIGHT BACK, ON THE BACKHAND.HE
EARLY GOING IS THAT WHEN THE
DUCKS TO GET POSSESSION OF THE
OUT OF THE CORNER NOW, PLAYS IT
BACK TO THE.
SABRES MOVE IT AROUND AND BRING.
I THINK IT MAY HAVE BUCKLED GO
IN THE OPENING PERIOD.
DUCKS LOOKING TO OF THE ZONE, D.
WANT AT
WHAT A MOVE BY ISAC LUNDESTROM
STOLARZ REVERSES IT BACK UP THE
BOARDS, AND IT IS RE
HERE IS THE ATTACK PLAY FOR THE
SABRES, THE PUCK WILL BE MOVED
INON, MOOSE IT ON RIGHT
WING.
DRYSDALE TRIED TO GET IT BACK TO
HIE
TO KEEP IT ALIVE FOR THE ANAHEIM
ZONE AND GETZLAF UP ON THE GOINT
OF THE CORNER, TRYING TO SKATE
HIS WAY IN DOORSTEP, BACK ANDRE.
WAS BEING LED TO THAT TIME BYCKP
.
TERRY FELL DOWN.
NOW SHATTENKIRK STEPS UP TO KEEP
IT. HE WAS BLOCKED.
INCOMES HEN FROM BEHIND THE NET,
STILL HAS THE PUCK BR HAVE BEEN
EARLY-SEASON RECALL THIS YEAR,
UP.
ASPLUND CIRCLES BACK.
STRETCHEHE